I wouldn't be a good person if I didn't share this information with you
Whole Foods has prepped meals that you can buy for 26.99
Look at all this food that you get
sweet potatoes
roasted chicken
and green beans
this can feed me for an entire week
or a full grown man for like four or five meals
I saw another tiktoker talking about this
I can't remember her name
she shared this information
and I think it was the same price
Apparently not all Whole Foods grocery stores does this
but look at how much food you get for $26
Are you kidding me
this is a meal preppers dream
I meal prep every week
and this is gonna save me so much time
because you get yummy
delicious chicken
sweet potatoes
I never eat those because they're too much work to cook up myself
and green beans
so simple, basic meal prep hack
I also bought these little meal prep containers
what I'm gonna do is just divide each portion
this literally made me so many meals
seven meals $26
I'm set for the week